all right and I am finally live game
blaster warning man flashpoint returns
my Manny but it's a lot going on in
destiny man first what are you doing
well pretty good just had a tasty
breakfast got a workout in kind of like
you but I'm just getting up and you're
getting ready to cash the candle there
but yeah yeah same deal here man is kind
of came back from work you know vampire
life is concluding roughly we good
workout week so I know it's gonna work
out because I did a legs the day before
and I'm still feeling man like that no
doubt everything doesn't matter when you
do heavy legs
you're gonna be walking funny for it yep
dad just started goes I had like my knee
was bothering me I had like a sore knees
like a week or whatever so this is like
the first week I got a chance to do
squats again sorry huh when little buck
Wow we look crazy try to catch him the
lowest knock here the body it's always
good so 12 drop this week in bungy 628
we has the next morning but they dropped
a whole bunch of stuff couple things
they didn't think we'd be talking about
but one thing I said to you sometimes
when I read through these so they're
giving us more information I feel like
they used to a little bit more here a
little bit more there but also on the
other end that just leads me to want to
ask more questions it's like kind of a
double-edged sword because I like the
fact that we get more info but when I
read through it there's other things I'm
like okay now that I have this knowledge
why why this why that why the other lake
I have more questions and then other
things don't make sense so no one say
that you've been real feisty with the
talk the drawers lately like I mean just
you know picking things apart thinking
through them it's just it's kind of one
of those words I wish I could be on the
floor fly on the wall and you've said
that a couple times it's like I just
want to know why decisions are made or
why if you know because they seem like
they know some things before we get to
know them and they know what's the thing
they like they know it's a thing they
hear feedback from us but then they we
wait like a month to tell us and then
we're like oh yeah you know but what you
feel like you knew earlier why didn't we
know it earlier so at least like for
example we'll get to it later but on
action rallies it's like hey why can't
you buy it it's like okay so it's an
issue with like the vendors as a more
mine they knew that when war my dad oh I
agree but they didn't tell us and be
like hey it's like we know right now
we're having an issue with vendors and
you can't buy the armor it is something
we're working on we know it's an orangy
thing we're just say that if you know it
and be like hey we are working on we'll
try and give it to you guys as soon as
we can as opposed to later on
acknowledging the fact that yeah we know
everybody seems to wanna buy it it's
like no kidding we of course we do so
it's just those types of things for me
that I'm like and again I'm probably
asking a little too much because we do a
lot but just would be nice when they
know something just be like hey just
drop it and be like we're trying we're
working it's not gonna happen right now
we'll get it to you as soon as we can so
now officially I don't think he asking
too much I think uh you know obviously
they've made tremendous strides this
year as far as transparency you know I
think I think the vibe I get from them
right now he is that um I think they
want to be careful with deliverables
because they know we take what they say
verbatim oh and I yeah for whatever
reason certain deliverables they don't
want to talk about initially but I mean
it's in there to fit its miles better
than like 2018 like somebody flipped a
switch or some leadership changed or
something like gate was open Activision
said whatever like I don't know what it
was but I mean that was just some
somebody somewhere was like okay
something's got to change like obviously
we have some stuff to work on they've
been trying to patch you know not quite
monthly but damn close and but when all
that stuff started to happen somebody
somewhere is like hey if they're asking
about it talk to them because it's got a
help so but yeah so what we are gonna
cover with you guys today is gonna be
this week at Bungie the main pieces of
course are gonna be the crucible changes
will cover faction release first just
because I had my rant you had your
chance to jump in this week so I want to
get your thoughts on it just a little
more direct feedback but the crucible
changes that are coming the prestige
raid layers that are finally going to be
released way way way way way later they
actually talked about collect
Asians coming up for forsaken which is
some good information and then we'll get
to a bit of rumors and things that
aren't exactly confirmed but seems to be
data leaked so we'll get to that a
little later so that's the general
rundown if that's what you guys are
looking for and we'll start it out
factionalized man let me hear from you I
want to know what's your thoughts
doesn't mean I had mine before I just
gonna want to know what you think
well obviously the first the one that
started the dead orbit movement started
for me when I'm fortunate when I was at
e3 so I could not do that faction
reality so this is my first week of
really going after the catalyst I'm a
graviton dude as most you guys already
know and um that catalyst must that must
be had at all costs I had to talk to her
do you had a conversation that this
would just be a temporary betrayal and I
but series audio design with a faction
rally um there's some good in it I mean
obviously I like the aspects of a
catalyst something of value behind the
faction I do like that aspect you know I
do feel the grind is pretty extreme you
know yeah you know to do rank 50 with
these packages cuz let's do the math
like what would you say would constitute
one package 2020 yeah that's 20 yeah
it's running ten right so basic exact
and that's a lot and then it comes down
to you know stuff that mean you've
talked to you talked about offline many
times which is you know the actual value
investment because you know if I'm by
for example
I've been doing a lot of glory crucible
this week okay nice shot sinister shout
the Lord addict you know I actually got
a child of that I try to got the
minimize like man just cuz it's that the
first time they were kind of all on at
the same times me yeah and I've been
dying to do glory crucible in any type
of a group even if it were not yeah I
tried solo it's tough it's luck of the
draw it there's no communication you
know you're kind of asking for it so you
know I did it with them and had a
tremendous time now I would say I was
getting about three to four don't quote
me but maybe three to four or something
along that maybe five faction tokens per
yeah and I'm like okay but you know I'm
saying again there's certain things I
feel that need to be levied and and we
talked about this like the nightfall
you know or heroic strikes or maybe even
put you know it ain't get no organized
those need to be ranked higher
absolutely for said activity you know
I'm saying the renown thing I love it I
love renown I have no problem with that
you know you go into the Lord it adds an
extra dimension you know you have to
think about your loadout because you
don't want to lose it
you know actually like the daily faction
reputation bundle that they do right
well you can kind of get like a sack of
20 if they you know whatever the random
thing is almost like a daily right I
don't mind that but they've got to do
something about the grind is a little
too long obviously we found out that
they're not selling the vendor specific
armor gear for the for the set so that's
another issue you know saying that
you're gonna fix it as we gonna be gonna
see but um there's still some tweaks
that need to be made and I don't trust
truck I don't want to complain about
grind too much because obviously there
was no grinding stuff when the Destiny
to you know whole thing started back but
there's got to be a balance here so I'm
curious to get your feedback on this
whole thing um I mean that's one of the
biggest things and I've heard it from
multiple people around there it's like I
said it my video I did I have my like 19
minute rant about this stuff
the renown is cool I like how it makes
them that feel you know little more
weight to it you got a plane your public
event playing like if you picked up you
know a what is it I'm trying to think of
it like an elite enemy and then you
finish your patrol and then you're going
into a public event to and already
you're like okay I gotta play
conservative pullback hopefully or not
everybody's playing the same way so it
gives a little weight to it then you
jump in the law sector now some are
easier than others the the one on Titan
with the ogre you can linear fusion
super him pretty quickly so I mean
that's efficient way to do it but then
in turn patrols can be a crapshoot
what if the public events aren't up so I
mean etz is another option because those
public events are up all the time
factors lost sectors everywhere so
it's kind of a balance of you're stuck
in a couple places doing a very
repetitive thing because it is the most
efficient and yes I mean try ro shout
out pirate on the pyro fantastic video
right now on farming tokens absolutely
but he also was like hey I did the raid
that's five tokens an encounter and
you're going what the hell oh that's
cool
see that I mean that's the level of like
how is that that way like if you do a
raid encounter give me like 25 because
whether it's I mean I sat there and I
was actually starting to go through
because yesterday it was the daily with
strikes before yesterday so I went
through and I was like okay arms dealer
and I literally wrote down my times
keeping a little tracking spreadsheet
owes like 11 minutes on an arms dealer
17 on Pier MIDI at night Sabbath UN's
twice that was 15 and 17 tree
probabilities was 14 twice and that was
with the void modifier but that was
Grenadier and grounded so not the best
not the worst um but it averaged 15
minutes and you get seven tokens yeah
that's still I can do a public event and
get five and then and some of those
public events where you've got like the
turn not the injection rig the other
couple one or you shoot the ship and you
blow that guy away in like ten seconds
yeah the speed that thing goes you're
like okay I'm done so just the weight of
the activities how that wasn't well I
mean they're like okay we want to give
lost sex or something but as you said
adventures no one does those so why
forget those raid nightfall strikes it's
like yeah so I have two options so I
need to do the daily so I have to do
three strikes but in the time of doing
that I could have probably farmed enough
public events and other things and had
about the same tokens even with the
daily bonus so it's like I haven't
touched crucible because crucible as you
said isn't worth my time right now right
so there's a lot of people who have
phrased that it's like I want to play
the way I want to and you're forcing me
to play this way because it's a limited
time event and this is what I was gonna
ask you on do you think there should be
one week only do you think it should be
all the time or do you think it should
be longer than it was just a week all
right I mean our first purpose I would
love it to be all the time I don't know
how logistical II work based on the
system of now
adding these catalysts involved and
maybe they just don't have enough
rewards at this current time to I'm just
thinking about the design process as to
why I wouldn't be there right they're
trying to add weight to the choice I get
that you know you want to make a tough
decision I mean it worked let's be are
like I'm new monarchy don't rule in
that's ten to shaders the whole mantra
the foolishness the royalty love it I
betrayed them because I saw that that
graviton Lance catalyst and for a
warlock day I of the another world
ornament is so fire to me cuz I never
really like the way I've been on another
world looked so um to see it look like
that am i oh I gotta have that
so that was marvel there you know um so
that they've got they got the part down
where the reward is worth it I mean he's
valuable right is is on that level and
the fact that um you now have to make
your choice and I like that it's account
while you can't really cheat and try to
have a warlock here on this faction and
your hunter on that I like that now the
key is the vendor when there's no
faction rally they are useless
absolutely that's a problem you can't
have can't have vendors in the tower a
useless that I just think that's wasted
and that's where the old system was kind
of good you can still kind of get they
had rotate weapons and that d1 they had
different things that you can get for
them so they still have to assign
something else to them to do when
there's no faction rally so I would be I
wouldn't be opposed to maybe a longer
rally maybe they're gonna keep it at a
limited time event maybe two weeks you
know I'm saying and then you know or
they stay and there's some type of
rotating inventory that's not that's
something that could think of right now
yeah no I mean I'm with you on that when
it's just like you cram a lot into the
week and for the average and it's like
if I work I get try and get my dailies
and I'll have a couple days like
depending on schedule or I can crying it
hard what I mean if I'm doing that
that's my couple days off just spent
doing just that and it's it's a lot of
time into one thing and as you're saying
now here's the other thing and this is
why they have a good idea of having an
account wide yeah
the only problem is your choice isn't
ever felt like you can stick with one
because you literally have to switch you
said it you're like I'm gonna go talk to
new monarchy and be like hey I got a
betray you it's short term I'll be back
like if you really wanted to like give
the lore a little bit more give your
weight of choosing a little bit more and
be like hey but it's kind of one of
those as I was saying before it's like
give them 50 levels and there's a token
and then you can pick a catalyst and if
you get your next 50 levels you stay in
there yes oh and then the same thing
with the orange you with the armor at
least if I grinded the first round the
second one won't be quite as bad no me
I'm starting over I got I'm level twelve
or thirteen so I've done like what 22
packages or something I have four pieces
but it could take me another 20 levels
to get the last one like I did last time
and it's not like you get like a little
bit of bonus it's all or nothing no so
just some benefits in there to either
getting what if it was every piece of
armor you wore as you built it up you
got one more token when you did
something yeah little bits like that
would give you something along the way
to ease the grind what I mean you still
gotta put in the time but give you a
little progress along so yeah I mean I
rented before so I don't want to go too
long I mean I've got a whole long point
one point but yeah so it's like I like
what they're doing but it's like they
got to wait the activities maybe if you
want to mess around with renown or
different modifiers or something to give
other things a challenge to go along
with it cool but right now it's just a
it's a very monotonous one I mean Paul
Tassie did an article pyro had the video
there are guides to do it efficiently
but it's the same crap over over and
over and over and over and it's yeah it
like you said I think the main thing you
knocked it out the part is that that's
depressing that you say pyro did a
portion of the Ray and got five right he
said like like alright what that's hard
huh yes
that's horrible right there just call it
for what it is so yeah I agree with you
they gotta fix that and like I said
hopefully that will come you know saying
cuz I'm seeing the bread it I'm seeing
the most people are saying the same
things so and they've been very to give
them credit
they've been very cognizant of ready in
these kind of things much more
quickly late lately so that's what yeah
yep
so yeah I mean that's my thoughts it's
like not perfect no the direct purchases
for armor are gonna be coming in 1.2.3
which we'll get to later and this is
what I was basically saying it's like
they knew it they knew they didn't have
it when it launched but and same with
iron banner that stuff's coming back so
it's just an ad with a vendor they're
working on fixing that guys so it is at
least in the works by the way shout out
to the picture up there I always love
these awesome yeah you just never quite
get a picture of the boss at this angle
and you look at you and it's like up
here he's got little tentacles on his
face and this and the big gun out it's
just it's nice to see the detail on
because the arts always amazing
absolutely shouts at our team uh
obviously if you guys didn't hear they
were at e3 and forsaken has come in
people some people got to play the story
mission and I've heard some interesting
things I'm not gonna go into spoilers
anything but I just can't wait to play
it yeah and then Forsaken sounds nothing
but good now there's some people have
said forsaken people have been kind of
like burning through the primeval if you
knew like a tractor cannon void but if
you like yeah I heard that from Steven
Riley I believe his name is yeah that I
said that yeah it's like you can kind of
cheese it if you got the right loadout
you know so it's kind of a balance like
do you set up and save everything for
that final push do you always go where
it's like I know there's gonna be
different strategies but if that
primeval can still be melted that fast
it's kind of like I instead of making
him spongy I'd rather see it staged with
mechanics if they can get to it well
personally because if it's just if it's
honestly just lots of health people will
find a way to be more and more efficient
with that but if there's mechanics to it
or you got to go pick something up even
if it's just like somebody run off to a
side of a map so there's three and that
would be kind of like a mechanic be like
hey there's an orb that spawned it pops
up on your like HUD but somebody's be
like hey I'm gonna go run this when you
guys hold it down so then it's the risk
of running for that next charge just to
drop his shield but then somebody could
come in and drop the other three who are
on yeah so I mean just something in
there to mix it up give you some like
gates that you have to go through just
to space it a little bit
absolutely - Chris Kolb in the chat he
can't wait for these changes yeah me too
man yeah we got a lot like I mean and
that's what we've said it's like all
these little pieces are these building
blocks the foundation of the pyramid so
hopefully they can put that in Kappa
forsaken on top of everything mm-hmm so
I mean III aside we've got a nice
calendar for July so I've got some stuff
coming first faction early winters week
obviously that's coming next week you
guys will know I'm going to war cult
I've heard a lot of people might so I
know Dylan of course on Twitter was
going straight up new monarchy so but
you know SunShot any any if you if you
guys with the first faction rally that I
missed any three most of you guys got
that catalyst so yeah you know you got
to go on to the next smartest thing and
the next one is definitely sunshine now
my question is um what's the ornament
for is there like you know like that
orbit gave the I have another world
what's the ornament that they give in
that that one is knucklehead radar and
it honestly doesn't look that different
so thank you so uh the final one is
crest above loop i-4 where the Titans
which I do actually like because it
takes that one and turns it into kind of
keeps the tone but it gives it more of
the new monarchy colors but it's not
like overly bright but anywhere does
exotic with the new monarch you said it
still can kind of fit The Bling mode so
yeah I kind of like that one so I was
like that one actually for an ornament
sounds cool and I kind of like the new
monarchy colors so that want to be last
and I haven't see I have the full armor
set there already would have had to bail
on it for the other two so at least I
start that one with a full armor set you
know so there's a little bit of jump
anyway Mayhem's coming next week in
bungee day nowadays always a thing so
what the question is they have it on the
calendar so do you think there's gonna
be anything for us mm-hmm
um I'm not sure steers gotta be
something they always do something I
mean they're big ol and said number
seven you know I figured the first thing
it'll be as a sail on the bungee shop
you can see Americas Asia but probably
do something very curious to see
what they do for that but they they're
so enamored and around the whole number
seven so it'll be it I think it's
definitely tied to that yeah and then
the week after
hyoeun banner will come back again
apparently just iron banner is gonna be
almost every other week it seems they
got faction relief action around the
week iron banner there's no much of a
break lately so who which okay with like
there should be something going on and
we'll get to some other activity maybe
coming in here - OH
Karim Khan is going so if you guys are
going to Cardian Khan sorry we won't be
there but to all of you guys that are
going enjoy forsaken and not forsaken
but enjoy gambit cuz that will actually
be playable mm-hmm but also honestly
guys I mean Guardian Khan it may have
like me I'm not going this year just
because timing everything else but also
they do some awesome stuff for charity
absolutely shout out to those bro man
all them guys man raised with the
collection of people and well I think
they're almost up to a million and they
haven't even got to that pre week yet so
literally it starts on the fifth up
until that weekend and I mean they're
already almost a million in this thing
hasn't started so it's always awesome
work that they do so if you guys are
looking for you know a little bit of
time to donate throw some money to a
good cause st. Jude's always a great
thing so July 17th we get patch 1.2.3 so
this is what we kind of briefly talked
about they're going to be fixing fixing
some of the vendors so you can purchase
the armor directly mmm outside of that
I'm not entirely sure what's coming this
seems like it's a little preview like a
pre patch for solstice of Heroes yes
good luck in which I'm digging the icon
by the way yeah that's kind of fire I
like it you know
affectionately final faction early of
season now here's a question Joseph so
final faction rally of season 3 is gonna
be July 23rd yes ok and it's gonna end
on the 31st and then you guys I know
it's gonna end on the 23rd and then 30th
so you have the whole entire month of
our August with no faction rally at all
right well that we know of right now
well I mean they've said it seems to be
pretty final so unless they like to
actually write because yeah cuz there's
the best
between the window between that and
forsaken so there won't be anything with
yeah you're correct
you want a minute um that's like why not
do one in a month I don't know if
they're using that to push other stuff
but it just kind of weird they're like
jammed them all here real quick and
early and they have a you know it's like
the way they seem to rotate you could
have another one in there in theory it
is interested in less again we don't
have an August move map right now so
they could be something inside you know
that they just don't want to talk
they're not ready to talk about you yet
yeah cuz actually it doesn't make sense
why August it wouldn't be there would be
one yeah my only question is if it's
ulcers of years if that's your like this
is your final grind this is your record
book starting to come in that's what I
feel like this has kind of got to be so
yeah I would I would think so oh yeah
supremacy is coming and we'll get some
crucible changes and things and then
finally we've got faction early winters
weekend solstice here's we know nothing
about solstice of years by the way guys
so ill your guess is as good as mine and
it's I mean it's a month away but I'm
get it's got to be somewhere in these
couple weeks because we're running out
of ideas so I don't know I mean I don't
what it is I mean like I don't think
it's gonna be srl I know a lot of people
do but I just I I I got a feeling it
wasn't a interview like it it doesn't
feel like this is the time for them to
go completely new racing mode no that
would be like okay by the way new event
we're gonna you know every seasonal
switch or something Forsaken might have
it but I don't think it's really oh yeah
that's the general that rundown of
what's to come
mm-hmm now crucible is next nowadays
much you have to look at some of these
changes there's quite a few yes so
crucible changes are coming patch 1.2.3
on the 17th oh I might let you just take
this one a little more than me there's
been a crucible week for me on in the
start of the weekend now shop send us a
shot at it got them to play some glory
crucible Whitney so the first time I
actually got chance to play as a team
and I had a lot we had a lot of fun we
actually did really well we had like
maybe won only one or two matches yeah
like a complete random that didn't know
you know anything it's kind of like
wasting the pool of deaths whenever we
did certain moves for a bit of fun but
yeah let's get to these things from
crucible playlist update
so we got quick play so increasing play
configuration is 6v6 and updating the
playlist description so the vibe I'm
getting 66 now in quick play just all
the time just all the time Daniel that's
literally they tried fours and
apparently just for more fun a little
more randomness it seems like 66 holdin
it down I'm cool with that you know say
removing next bullet point removing
supremacy from the pool of available
game modes interesting lesson premises
being removed out okay control updating
control win score 150 control zones will
initially be neutral clash updating
clash win score to 100 then we have
competitive bomb fuse timer and
countdown lowered from 40 seconds to 35
seconds my to change I actually like
that I actually like that just a little
more urgency to it yeah make it
objective base make it more urgency with
that objective because I'm noticing a
lot of people just go out for the kills
and they're not about that so then we
got general rumble will become a full
time playlist that's cool last episode
where people shout out pressure yeah
shout out to them down south antenna to
unknown player I know that they stay
rock out and crumble a lot they wouldn't
mop the floor if me it'd be terrible
yeah a beast then we got so supremacy
will also be added to the weekly
featured playlists updated to 6v6 and
have a wind score of 150 so that's
curious that supremacy is moved into
competitive as it seems right no it's
just another weekly rotation like in the
middle okay okay so it'll be like
doubles or supremacy or gotta move
quickly
yep from the pool so it's interesting
that they don't want supremacy in
quickly I find that interesting
yeah I don't mean I don't know if it's
pushback that not as many people like
the mode but they still want to give
people an option to it I mean that's my
only guess I know some people were like
I even saw on Twitter somebody was like
oh thank you so I know I don't know what
it is if not everybody loves Kill
Confirmed or I mean that's just my guess
it's like just you back given a rotation
so it's not completely gone but you know
taking just the basics you got
control that's your quick play modes and
that I mean it kind of makes sense just
so you want to jump in a match control
or clash they're pretty basic
straightforward no no worries too much I
mean it's nice to have a little bit of
an objective you got to be up on them
you can't just like snipe but nobody
does but I mean it's nice to have a
change I don't know okay either way I
don't love the mode but I don't hate it
the way some people yes I've never
really hate it and maybe I think it's
what you said but maybe they have the
metrics and the numbers and you know
just not a mode that either people are
enjoying our people backing out baby
elbow feels like supremacy is being
punished out of the could get our little
circle over here you go we play this
rotation you know so that's interested
but I will say this I like 66 though
anything 6v6 I'm about that you know
yeah I was like most of the time I'm
usually pretty good on there's the
occasional time spawns will flip and
then I'm like why am I being I'm like
half dead before I'm even really aware
of what's going on is just once I
flipped a little bit cuz there's just a
bigger spread of people and I think this
is one thing to that may sex I had a
good question some of the maps don't
quite fit 66 so much of destiny 2 was
built for for absolute the maps were
developed that way everything was
designed around four before they went
hard on it now that they have to change
yes aren't I mean they can kind of work
like distant shores I think is what it's
called you know what she used to be
short of time that one's got more space
because it was a d1 map right so same
with banner fall too so those type have
more space to work with but there's just
some of them they feel a little more
cramped sometimes and it's they don't
like if you really think about all the
space on them the map isn't per se be
that much smaller right but it's just
somehow that they're set up that it
always seems to be like six just doesn't
quite fit always so I get what you say
I'm hoping I think basically he was
saying is that I'm hoping with forsaken
the more maps are built with 66 in mind
yeah we just have a little more spread
in different options involved I would
agree definitely so as we continue on
this one I love II know I know I mean
this should have been that way from the
start but go ahead
Crucible ranks update players will now
be able to earn valor rank from
additional playlist competitive crucible
labs iron banner and trials up tonight
thank God because I've been playing band
a very hardcore you know the past couple
of weeks and um it just sucks like you
know like I have to leave iron banner to
go play regular Valor to even get any
Valerie like these are regular
activities as almost like a quick play
casual mode so those modes should be
involved with gaining Valerie your
crucible at all that's what valor isn't
it to be it's just your time spent in
the crucible that's there's a real
there's no competitive edge there's no
like kill death ratio nothing it's just
your time in crucible and if you're in
there in any shape fashion or form yeah
just like that
that's that's one of those questions I'm
like I would have probably pushed art
they're like no we wanted to be like
this playlist like no you're in crucible
you clicked on the button you get Valor
I don't exactly oh that is his time
commitment really right just two
crucible in itself it's not you know you
can't lose rank and all other stuff so
yeah that had to happen I felt it was
dumb I placed so much iron man I'm like
yeah I didn't get any talent for that
like and reward the guys that actually
play your your mode you don't say like
this is a mole you know for the most
part yeah I don't know what the
percentages are in destiny to but I
would assume you know based on the way
destiny to started that people did not
like crucible right but I believe you
know before before a change was tough on
some people I know myself I did not like
trials I still don't like trials a lot
of people who don't it draws a big part
of destiny you know at least it wasn't
destiny one in destiny one yet trials I
remember trials was so good during
destiny one that during the the Dark
Ages of like content droughts trials was
carrying destiny play account was hot so
you know things like that you want to
reward your community that it's actually
oil to the mole I'm agreeing with this
like what those guys give them kind of
stuff you know and give that community
love you know and all they got to do
still
still haven't done it yet we'll see what
happens when Bounty's comes his bounties
is coming soon on that development map
is they got to bring back an equivalent
besides cause their arms they need an
equivalent to the trembling of warbound
absolutely we need that for them for the
crucible guys like me cuz sometimes I
just mindless shoot up some stuff I
don't have time for you know the full
strikes and the race I just want to get
you know my meta on and mess around gun
types and stuff and that's my thing you
know I do like the crucible and destiny
so this is good to see but I've rambled
on long enough about right now so
joining a game in progress will protect
your valor win streak for that game if
you lose no penalties encourage your
valor win streak if you win valor win
streak increases what do you feel about
that I mean yeah it's your time in
crucible so I mean if you join the game
in progress it's less in your control
whether it's you know a minute in or
whether it's halfway through the match
depending on when you join it's like
I've joined some and it's like okay
you're like five points apart now and
people may be switching so someone may
have an advantage but if you joining
you're like you jump in it's like 10 to
50 or like well that's I mean you might
be there is a few people who could make
enough of a difference to come back and
there may be a few more points involved
but man like if you're starting at a
deficit that's not your fault yeah yeah
I also like the fact that like if you do
manage to pull it out I'm gonna join a
good ciass good like valor should never
work against you it really shouldn't
then we have players will be matched
using their glory rank this means your
opponents will be of similar rank to you
the higher you climb the tougher the
opponent glory law streets alright will
be retuned to be less punishing over
time consecutive losses will decrease
the rank points lost instead of
increasing and streaks will still cap
out at 5 and then the last point when
all rank streaks will no longer reset
once they hit their cap interesting
interesting interesting leverage of it
is all apart
interesting cuz I just started really
going hard this week with it
I want my rhetoric sang a lot because
it's really in my opinion the universe
of good PvP where I really use it for
pde I think you have tremendous
potential as a good spot yeah man
so um alright so here's a do you know
your poll it will be of similar rank to
you okay fine
the higher you climb tough for the
opponent okay fine so the algorithm is
I'm assuming changing directly to this
now right as opposed that's how it
should be so if I jump into glory I'm
not going up against somebody just
because they have a decent connection to
me exact 2,000 points in glory and I'm
just getting mopped like I don't need to
be great
it's just interesting like I had to say
that continuum job no but it's like this
is almost in your ladder type like not
ladder but tears like if I'm at a
hundred there's no way I should be
playing against people yes that's where
I need to be now if you jump up for it
cool but if you stay there that's the
level that you fight oh and that's I
match make you should be done just
straight-up skill facts I'm with I'm
with that alright
glory loss tricks this is the
controversial the one that they saying
they're gonna be retuned to partly to be
less punishing overtime I'm okay with
that
um consecutive losses will decrease the
rank points lost instead of increasing
okay they trying to not not it for it to
be as punishing and streaks will still
cap out f5 now arm here's the thing you
know but I know this is a big thing in
the crucible community shout out to all
my dudes from my reddit no strain was
too crucible playbook that those are my
guys out there um I've seen a lot and
you know even on regular ready I'm on
destiny I'm seeing a lot of people
saying that it should be removed all I'm
saying is be careful right remember what
God has here again I get it people are
frustrated it's happened to me you know
I was I was playing solo I had a good
run to three matches in a row
boom boom boom and then the next thing
you know I lost four to five straight
and I just see my my glory is evaporate
yeah it's demoralizing I'm not gonna sit
here but part of me I'm not gonna lie to
you now I'm gonna probably be the
minority on this probably likes the fact
that it's there you have said because at
the end of the day dish weapon these
things are not supposed to be attainable
right for the average or below average
crucible player you have to make a
dedication you have to get good you know
if for the people who saying they want a
remotely I don't mind them lessening it
I'm cool with that
but I just don't want them to listen to
everyone and say remove it because we're
gonna be in a situation early that's the
- everyone's gonna rank up there's no
penalty everyone's gonna get a rhetorics
where's the specialty in it okay so let
me ask you ask you this that's cuz you
don't lose you're gonna lose some so
it's real like like I mean if I jump
into five random matches with randoms
and I still lose I'm dropping some right
so it's not like if I just you know
half-ass my attempts in there that I'm
gonna get red or exclaim or oh now would
you'd rather have it to where there's no
streak either way we're just straight-up
wins losses no I don't want that so
whole stream yeah I listen I get why
people shout at the Crisco he's like I
hate it it's a bad baby V is that no he
said I don't hate it but it's bad in you
people
the reason being again this is the best
of the best
glory crucible right let me ask you look
again let's go what if the higher your
rank climbs the penalties are bigger I
mean different I guess it does I just
like throwing out ideas cuz like for me
if I go in I don't have anybody on PC to
play crucible with so me going in there
is gonna be straight-up randoms and
ohnpeace it's sweaty as hell right it is
for me like picturing this it's like the
law streaks stills like I make it to a
hundred and I'm gonna be right back and
I feel like I'm barely gonna be able to
get out of like the hundreds if I ever
do so part of that's just like I know
not all can get there and
it's you don't like it you know nobody's
I'm just trying to think it's like I'm
okay with the loss taking it away from
you and maybe the like win streak isn't
quite as much if the so what if the win
streak wasn't as big of a boost but the
loss didn't have like the you know
compounding amount to it like if the
loss was always the same amount and say
if you had a good run going but if you
lose like five so if you lose five in a
row say you lose five points each night
okay if you win it's like five six seven
eight nine ten like you get like more
each time so it's not surrounding and
you got still gonna put it in but you're
still but it's not a big difference so I
mean they're so worried going I see we
going I still disagree again you know I
think this is as close Bungie has tried
to replicate their halo system all right
yeah you had the ranks and you go up you
know listen I may never get this weapon
you don't say oh now here's where I see
what you're going as a solo player and I
agree with the frustration here or I
think that's more result of their
terrible matchmaking said okay I can
agree with that yeah exactly to say look
II bought this is a solo player right
now we need to cue him up even if the
wait time is a little longer
yeah with a whole bunch of other solo
players so that the team's order if
there's if the algorithm says look
there's not enough solo guys left for
him to fight then we're gonna put him up
against a team that is ranked of maybe
at his level or a little lower so that
it's not a mop fest right - at least you
got a shot with the solos you got you
never say that to me if bungee had a
better driver and a better that's your
like this would be the issue he just
wished suffering because it it but I
hate what you saying I think that's
probably a fair balance - it was like if
the matchmaking was legit and I was like
I always went in I never saw anybody in
a clan and I was always playing solo and
it's like and you're gonna have your
time so I was like hey we do well hey
they did well it's like and if it felt
somewhat balanced
but it's also the point of like yeah
it's like if sometimes if it's 50/50
sometimes and then the other 50% I'm
against teams and I'm just straight up
at a disadvantage that law streak for me
is gonna be a factor a lot so that's
just why for solos for sure but I mean I
can understand both ways I think
matchmaking that probably is the trump
card of all that means absolutely but
yeah yeah I knew this is a little touchy
so I wanted to touch on I know I'm in
the minority and listen I'm not against
these changes that are currently made
right here I'm okay with them you know
decreasing the rank points on the loss
and stuff like that and streaks capping
out five and you know the rank streets
no longer resetting wants to hit the cap
I'm cool with that
my only thing they need to add to be
completely honest you see how they did
for valor when they said hey if you join
something in progress there's been many
times see that I'm surprised that's not
in glory that's what I was just about to
say why is that not and good because
there's been times where like I play and
like let's say the other team jumps out
out on us I'm playing solo dudes they
just leave and my thing is why do I stay
there and suffer and still like you
gotta reward the guy who just stuck it
through yeah you I'm saying like for
that don't exactly don't play me because
he he didn't leave he wasn't a clown and
and I agree I think they shouldn't get
penalized at all if you finish it and
it's four guys to two or four guys to
three like that's an unfair balance you
know what I mean yeah private crucible
you know I had to grab that one like I
mean just glory yeah I mean it's kind of
one of those if you don't start and end
with a complete team or there's an
inactive person that gets tagged for a
certain like some of that stuff needs to
be factored in and maybe somebody's
inactive for like a minute then they
barely jump in that's still first minute
could be an issue it's like take some of
that stuff in just to the scoring where
maybe it's not quite as much or if
somebody leaves don't deduct you just
call it null and void give you other
people an increase you're not hurting
that much so yeah absolutely absolutely
so we got a prestigious offensive let
you guess so
prestige raids are finally coming whoo
yeah curse of Osiris was
in December am i right so long ago no it
is almost July so yeah six months later
yeah press these layers they've been
trying to figure out how to work them
what to do with them finally got us an
answer and I guess it's like you're a
here's something fun to do for the
summer if you haven't burned out of
destiny yet so we've got a couple
options they're gonna be it's with one
point two point three so it's July
seventeenth if I can remember dates
right oh yeah July 17th so they will be
coming in a couple weeks
first off they are going to it's the two
raid layers not the main raid that's
still just as it is we're not changing
so prestige Leviathan still straight up
normals okay now so what you get wanted
to do is they wanted new activity
modifiers which are gonna be around
prism is gonna be one of them so
depending on the rotation of what
modifiers are gonna be there they're
gonna be ones that can't help you as
well just completely throw you under the
bus which there has to be a balance with
what's coming later now what do you get
now this is interesting I saw something
on Twitter and I'll get to it in a
second by doing prestige raid layers you
can get four hundred level so what's
this about so the only way to get four
hundred power armor before Forsaken is
by participating in the summer solstice
event so there's something coming with
summer solstice you're gonna like prep
they're giving you a little prep for
forsaken so that's what that months
gonna be as opposed to affection or
allies I guess so I can like cap Bob yep
and but the only way to get four hundred
power weapons before Forsaken is
completing pressed so weapons not armor
this is for weapons only isn't prestige
spire the stars an eater of worlds M
every time you complete all the
encounters and a prestige raid layer so
you have to go start to finish you'll be
rewarded with a four hundred power raid
weapon now it says every time there's no
limit so this can be any raid weapon
from destiny to not
just the ones that drop in there so any
raid weapon Indy to Olive Leviathan
weapons are on the table which is good
because just only like two and two in
that raids so all those are not raid
armor ornaments each fresh stage rare
Laurie Blair has its own unique armor
ornaments exotic mastery catalysts both
raid layers have mastered catalysts that
can only that are gonna be a rare drop
oh so there's a couple and we'll get to
the catalysts what I can I switch over
here once we get them something like
this so first what do you think about
the you can get 400 by only doing the
prestige raid what do you think I mean
different I don't I don't think there's
anything necessarily wrong with disobey
them again let me clarify 400 power
armor is not available in that layer
trustees layer but 400 power weapons are
and they can be from any of the three
survived in spire stars basically of
that pool is that correct yeah any
Leviathan weapon is an option in their
only weapons not armored up to 400 now
when they say power weapons just the
power slap like the legend of aqueous
slap 400 light level that what should be
how they said it okay cuz I see power
I'm like okay my stuff they're like sins
in the past yes okay got it so pretty
much any weapon that any raid weapon
right or yeah anyway weapon from that's
not just weapons wrapping out where so
any raid weapon comes in our 400 there's
a possibility yeah I don't know about
that I'm cool with that
I'm fine what what do you think you you
know you're not feeling it no I actually
am honestly because what I saw on
Twitter and this is what I was gonna say
somebody's like I can only get up to 400
what else do you doing right for seconds
gonna be 600 so this isn't gonna matter
in about you know oh into forsaken so
this isn't a minute this is something
for those right now and how many things
the power level really matter Krissi's
balls is literally probably the only one
who you might have a little bit more
easier time running the raid you
put some effort in on a raid and then
the raid gets a little bit easier what
yeah oh I mean I'm honestly a hundred
percent okay with it because me if I
don't have that much time to raid hey I
might end up capping out at about 385 if
I get like randomly in there once I
might get through 86 who knows well what
is still not going to matter too much
once four-second comes out we're going
to blow the doors off it but those who
do like to rate those who like to
prestige those who like to help other
people right now especially if we're
gonna have like moments of triumph and
things like that it gives you a benefit
to doing this so you don't feel like
you're you know gonna go work on a
triumph or need to rate a couple more
times it gives you a reason gives you
something else to work for so I
absolutely I like it like iris this was
kind of a thing I did this yeah I think
this is a cool thing going for it
because I know people in my class out
the sister shout out to attic
um they love they love that if they
grind it that they just got a little bit
of power advantage over yours that like
they love that stuff but their showcase
like hey look you know they're like okay
and then also it gives incentive to
continue its like mid tier like leveling
that's what I feel like right before a
big release right so if you incentive to
run you know I'm saying to run the raids
give you a little bit more incentive you
don't I mean I think it's cool that
there are other things we're gonna talk
about because some things yeah we gonna
get into that so if you finish with this
one let me know okay so next now how do
you get this stuff what does the
prestige raid lair gonna be so each week
there's a curated weapon suite
oh wait wait can we go back because we
skipped over our mess
we skipped over a dorm armor ornaments I
said it but yeah go ahead alright you
said it I mean okay we didn't skip it
but technically you said it um as far as
the ornaments I love that but we got
talked about that catalyst New England
wind breeze past that okay all right all
with this alright here's why it's okay
first of all we did same you want rare
drops and things from the raid so I
don't want to be a hypocrite right
we all know these catalysts are the
thing right now if anything they didn't
wore mine that to me has knocked it out
of the park is that catalyst crime you
want that favorite exotic of yours and
you want it maximized and whatever you
know bonuses they give it so when I hear
that the rate layers will have a master
work catalyst that can only be there
could be found only as a rare drop give
me crack the code of vibes bad red rare
drop that means I could run it like at
least with the other arm catalyst
there's specific activities right you
know or specific things kill this amount
of enemies you know the verbage is
always telling you what to do
specifically to hit some people who run
300 prestige nightfalls just to get an
exotic catalyst for one of those do you
think that's right either
but who's got a catalyst it what is what
catalyst is in the come from strikes are
a pain in the butt which one you talking
about I'm confused because I catalyst
that comes from strikes hold on let me
pull them up which one are those yet
break it down break them down heroic
strikes and night falls cold heart
merciless Prometheus lends risk runner
and war color coil there's some there's
a reason because you don't have them yet
strikes and night falls that's where
those come from but they're a random
drop in there people have run hundred
some-odd strikes no drop that's tough
that's real real low if it's this I'm
not gonna do a hundred raids hoping for
it well I'm probably not even gonna have
enough time for 105 like they got a
tweet that a little you know I I'd like
I like that it's in that activity but
when you randomize and stuff like I
literally like one out of a hundred a
roll and I'm and I strike out a lot
freaking out some people said they ran
like five hundred prestige then there's
like prestige nightfall you know makes
it better
some guy was like finally running here I
think he ran five hundred prestige night
falls to get all five of them
that's insane ripped heart that's like
yeah it's insane there's a balance of
stuff to grind for but that's that's too
much yeah man I mean listen at the end
of the day again I don't mind that their
lot to an activity but it should be
something like okay no you kill the
Cabal or like you know a check maybe
make it random at a chance at a boss if
you're gonna go to crunch of crota rock
right you knew when you got to eight or
whatever who was I mean when you got
scrolling right um that you know you
dropped there you know I'm saying at
least specify at the specific boss or
whoever right but did you say random
drop in this huge raid like that's a bit
that's too much playing a Powerball but
there's not even checkpoint so I mean
you gotta run the whole raid anyway so
yeah yeah I don't know how I feel about
that I'm gonna be honest like I gotta
see the drop rates I'm gonna reserve
judgment until it's out in a while right
I'm not gonna go crazy just yet Devaraj
to me got me cringing because the way
the strikes have been if it's anywhere
remotely to that people are gonna have
them at all
and somebody's catalysts are really good
yes I mean inspire styles and in spire
stars and then hope wishing a dream when
this thing gonna drop yes
motivate speeds up weaponry weapon
charge time that's the best thing that
could happen
accelerated coils is literally gonna be
what the perk is on sleeper simulant I'm
like yep that just became amazing even
more so than before so but I mean think
about the stuff and the strikes you've
got cold heart 20 stability 20 reload
speed okay merciless 40 range 40
stability dude merciless laked
prometheus lens same thing risk runner
30 range on a submachine
yeah or clip oil improve tracking on
projectiles like all of those things
they're like good just like game
changers on those facts so yeah no the
the drop rate on some of these has got
to get fixed I don't know if there's a
way and a security and radio before
because if you if you make it a checkbox
where you run it ten times you know like
you know what it takes to get there
that's like it's but somehow there's got
to be a way to balance like you know run
it ten times then you know for sure you
have it versus run it 500 times and you
might not like there's got to be a low
level in there that's somewhere to walk
a middle line so I don't know but I'm
with you on the exotic catalysts like
some some of that stuff some of the if
there's like if there's a crux of Curtis
something like that specific to the rate
itself cool now if it's a legend of a
curious catalyst and it's from there you
know maybe that one's a little harder
but if it's a catalyst for something we
got from war mines expansion or Telesto
or sky burners oath like those are from
the raid but those are not all raid
related so that's why it's I don't know
whoa
there's yeah a whole lot of questions I
want to see drop rate stuff like that so
back to where we were so each week there
is a curated weapon suite and a global
activity modifier for spire of stars and
eater of worlds the weapon set and
modifier will be the same across both
activities so curated weapon loadouts
are based on weapon archetypes over the
summer you might see a combination that
requires auto rifles submachine guns and
sniper rifles or Scout rifles hand
cannons rocket launchers lately
now weapons aren't locked but you just
have to fall within that archetype so
you could use you know if it's auto
rifles and submachine guns so you guys
gave luck you got you know anything like
that and then buy so it just has to fit
in that archetype and you can even bring
multiple with you if you need one that's
a little slower and longer range for
callous when you're in the dark zone
then cool or if on the other side you
need something where you pop a rift and
your submachine guns got a little more
range but you can blow through it like
there's gonna be certain things that
work better than others for so lots
whoa now we got to talk about lot is it
a saint they're saying it's not locking
the next step right right so you have to
be an auto rifle in your kinetic slot
for example but once you pick your auto
rifle and you load in the raid you can
switch auto rifles if you bring like six
auto rifles with you you can move to
different ones if you need it for
different activity I guess my question
though is date like in trials it's
locked or prestige 94 it's locked
right when you don't have when you you
know whatever it's not that way but my
question is what if I broke protocol and
arm switched it to a weapon that's
outside of that you know that pattern
won't let you switch it that's what I'm
saying so pretty much it's gotta be
let's say it's auto rifles submachine
sniper right and I went off origin story
and I started to put better Devils it
like better though should be grayed out
right yep it will be okay that's all I'm
saying yeah yeah you might have to bring
them with you I don't know if you'll be
able to like dim like use dim and switch
stuff in between yeah but it may just
like you know do a quick check like if
you're in the raid if there's something
like a hand cannon your kinetic slot
it's just great out you can't click it
so that's my guess is how it go they're
shipping three activity modifiers with
the raid layers to rotate between two of
these are gonna be brand new which I'm
kind of curious the other one is gonna
be prism which it's that rotating thing
now if prisms up hard light it's gonna
be a big one or you're just gonna have
to know like okay when prisms up you've
got to rotate or make sure your team has
a decent spread of all types of damage
oh so you guys can spread it out I'm
kind of curious what the other two are
gonna be you got any ideas since they're
brand new built from the ground up just
for the raid this is it just a bit I
have no idea I'm very cute to see what
they cook up I swear to God if it's
another variation of grounded crap like
I don't know if you guys have seen some
of the articles out there
Slayer Age did a huge reddit post Paul
Tassie did one on it
heroic strike modifiers mostly they all
suck yeah yeah so I'm like because I
mean what is it grounded
you literally your whole ability as a
guardian is to jump so and then what
about the points when you're doing the
will of the thousands and he puts the
hore on fire you have to have to jump
late there's a strike and you could have
random I have to jump but I'm gonna get
killed if I do and it's pretty much
against to kill if you're up there it's
one or two shots if you're lucky so
please don't make them that terrible
hopefully they're ones that help you not
hurt you quite so bad we'll see each of
the modifiers is designed to provide the
Guardians with advantages over the
enemies when they lean into it so you're
gonna have to kind of pay attention we
have a load of Milich I let's go you
might want to watch what's going on
we'll see the goal of using these
modifiers and low deaths is to change
the way you engage the prestige rate
every week first week the modifier and
weapon loadouts might synergize really
well with a strategy stand armored
exotics you've been using for months
next week
completely different so it's kind of a
way to mix it up looking to balloon luna
faction boots might have to change it up
we'll see so love a little fashion who's
already started you I need to run the
raid for a little while with those
because I'm pretty sure you can just
melt most things I'm so excited to do
Calais but I haven't run Callan so long
but with Luna faction oh dude it's
excited baby stationary boss oh yeah
it's a DPS phase alright I like really
hold on a sailing football boots alright
groups for trio probabilities I mean you
could melt that guy cuz he lands in you
can stun him and then you just sit there
and unload and it's just like people
would actually know what by the way
shout out to everybody who's running
heroic strikes pay attention if you're
running make it heroic don't burn
through the taken public event without
turning it into a heroic oh my god
encounter sorry anyways
tangent ran low avoid gödel I love it I
love it is anything happened to the
prestige for the Leviathan raid nope
don't need
there's just nope but it does say it
might be worth going back and playing
some Leviathan prestige to see if cows
as a new way to enhance one of your
favorite shotguns well a crius is gonna
have its catalyst in there so that's
pretty obvious
our prestige raid lairs getting pre
encounter changes our encounter changes
no so the mechanics are gonna be the
same it's literally just what if
modifiers and weapons are involved no
changes no mechanics no different things
in there and honestly I kind of missed
that like the prestige raids or taking
king when they did those and like how
would you you know do the procedure how
would you get that extra chest or
something like that you had to do the
specific mechanics that was part of the
fun so I do those
how many prestige raid activities will
be active for each week all of them now
for those of you who want to run the
raid race pick one or the other because
they're both going to be going on when
it goes live the other literally sank
current plane is for both prestige
Slayers to be active with modifiers
right when the patch goes live so come
the seventeenth one 1.2.3 comes out pick
your battle and see which one to see how
they go I think most people would
probably knock out eater of worlds first
to get some higher stuff because it's
faster and I think most people know that
encounter better and then probably go
hit spire later but that's just a guess
alright so I mean that's mostly it for
prestige what do you think overall about
that before we get to what's coming up
next oh I think this is overall positive
I didn't expect a lot of this to be
completely honest with you I think the
the whole power armor you know weapons
stuff is pretty cool it gives you a nice
little you know mid chase the light
level chase in between for people who
want more stuff to do plus a little
incentive for the raids like um I like
to curate it uh loadout I think that's a
pretty cool thing you know just to run
like shout out the cactus he has some of
the best they call him um you know
versus yeah I liked his rage for dummies
those are the greatest
but he's um he's got this thing with
like let's say for example sleeper
simulant just comes out he'll be like
sleeper stimulant in the Leviathan and
he'll he'll use it in each section and
rape the weapon in each section right so
it reminds me of something like that
because
like you're gonna have to come up with
what's the best weapon archetypes for
each encounter with that loadout you
know say and I think that's cool I love
me personally I like the minutiae and
stuff like that so no a sniper or a poem
I gotta grab that door see now you know
I'm saying you know kind of stuff like
that I think it's cool you know I
actually like that I hope you know the
rewards seem like they're gonna be big
and um yeah I'm excited to see what this
is gonna be and how people take to it
what do you think I mean I'm the same
way I think all stuff is positive I mean
it'd be really brutal if if they did
like sidearm submachine gun and sword
yeah yeah they'd be kind of rough cuz
that be nearly impossible but as long as
it's reasonable and the modifiers kind
of give you a way to as they said if you
lean into the modifiers if you pay
attention it's probably gonna be I think
all right and overall I just kind of
liked the idea I mean if you can get to
400 by grand and press these nightfalls
doing these specific load outs you have
your X to the 15 power level because you
want to know the big thing power level
doesn't mean squat right now yeah grand
for so those people getting bent out of
shape about it I think you're you know
making you know what forsaking drop
that's when it's gonna matter and that's
when the weapons don't get bumped up so
again it was a 400 but like in the first
two story missions exactly you you'll be
fine
yes a shout the positive check we
discusses discusses a faction rally
strategies so have the Chris they
talking about they use it a little back
into public events at retail
yeah people liking the what I call it
pyro method which is just keep running
those um and run a public event load the
same spots see if it's active a couple
trying again
but shout-out to Chris Kohlberg because
he I know what he's talking about with
the lost sector on Titan and he's saying
yeah you just it's one boss the ogre
moves out yeah bulbs he what he's doing
is he's sleeper in him melting him and
then just letting grab the thing and get
now yeah I took a linear fusion rifle
cuz it's because it's so fast if you do
a rocket he Wiggles enough to travel
right you gotta like not quite right
this sleeper or any religion linear
fusion like tarantula I got the dead or
the one those are an option as well so
any linear fusions actually really solid
because the crits are powerful
absolutely whole decent I mean but again
it's still public that wants extra
public event loss sector a public public
no but like let me go still have a
little like you said let let us run a
knife fall and really get a drop and if
you do a raid like you should be getting
like ten to fifteen to twenty you know
I'm saying you should be getting I'm
doing alright maybe you get less if you
repeat the raid but the first time you
do a raid for a week yeah yeah I agree
I completely rude you know so
collections so this is going to be
coming with hold on I want to look at
the roadmap real quick gear collection
so this is gonna come with forsaken so
this will be September for but what
they're basically saying is collections
are going to include basically
everything we've got from year one no no
no if this is a good way to balance out
your vault a little bit with random
roles and stuff coming right we'll go
through these questions kind of hit them
all up and then kind of wrap up our
thoughts after we get through so what
items from year one inventory will the
collection track weapon armor ghost ship
Sparrow emblem or shader available in
year one who's basically everything but
I can think everything yes everything
except consumables so I'm not
consumables the things that are used up
turn in photos and stuff like is there
anything I can dismantle before for
second watch now how much you trust
bungee is what this question is data
reason you have an item in your
inventory right now you can safely
discard it and retrieve urban
collections in September this does not
include consumable so hang on to those
now what when was it active from warmind
on so if you have it now you can
dismantle it if you had it back in
January and got rid of it that's not
hold done but since war mind they
probably pulled a big you know inventory
set and then since then they've been
keeping track so if you need to go
through delete some you know some old
guns some crap you don't use and you've
got it now you should be able to lead it
to delete it and should be able to get
it from a gear collection later if you
desire mm-hmm
I like this because this is really gonna
start helping people's inventory if you
want to go through it now some of us are
like I don't I don't know if I trust you
yet until I see actually in the
collection I'm not gonna delete it so
some people won't do it but per them to
be there so I'm not gonna delete like
all my exotics and stuff like that right
but what items from you two can be
required from collections so with the
addition of random perk roles see this
is when it can gets interesting
random perk roles are coming in we had
to make tough call for collections we
investigated numerous options for gear
with random perks fixed collection perks
five act limits rerolls all the other
stuff but each of these came with issues
ultimately we decided to stable purchase
of all year two random rolled legendary
weapons and armor interesting so
basically you better hold on to that
guard role right yeah if you get them
keep it but um if it's a god Road you
probably should want to which is what
kind of logical anyway but the nice
thing is like we're getting 200 more
spots what you have in year one that's
kind of crammed in your inventory and
everything full hopefully we can pick
and choose and be like there's like ten
pulse rifles I don't use let me delete
most of those keep my couple good ones
and ease up some space so this actually
should help right hopefully with 200
more spots at least it's getting there
so I'm liking that right now this is one
thing to see how much you want to read
into it ultimately decided to disable
all year to random rolled legendary
weapons and armor so two things to take
from that one weapons and armor are
gonna have random role perks of some
nature how many we don't know but to
what nature they will be some randomness
to these I'd like to see like two or
three random perks as opposed to like
just like one on the boy if it's the one
that's gonna suck like seriously so but
the other piece about it is and I was
listening to I can't quite remember who
I'd still like to see you stuff like
tonight all exclusive rewards or raid
weapons that drop be legendary
but have some really epic fixed roles
well
just like oh I can't think of the best
hand cannon in D 1 you had a couple you
know what's a breaker hey bring one I'm
thinking of like yeah just like
legendary raid stuff should be upper
tier set I think like because
unfortunately the random rolls when you
got to taking king when they went to
that for the first time sucked most of
those were terrible and you go through a
raid and it's like there's or at least
make the options smaller so if the
options are there it's like one
stability ones ranged both are decent
neither suck like if you're gonna have
randoms limit the really you know upper
echelon activities to mostly good
options only because I know they're not
stupid I know they know all perks aren't
good so that'd just be my one ask
they're okay how much will it cost to
reacquire items out of collections we're
currently working on cost for the items
have more or two later they two main
goals when reacquisition isn't a
currency sync they don't want you to be
able to just you know don't money in or
don't want to make you need to I'm not
trying to make you spend all your
hard-earned glimmer of which why the cap
isn't higher I don't know but they want
to make sure that if you find out I've I
remember syns and this kind of an
interesting shader dismantles into
glimmer glimmer shader just main tools
from ever verse and it's bright does
cost bright just I mean it seems to make
sense so most of that seems okay to me
um a lot of you been asking about the
cost of shaders we can't say the cost to
a reacquire shader from collections they
will have a cost but you no longer have
it cost to apply the shaders thank God
yeah if you have it just slap it on
there like if I have a bucket of paint
let me use the bucket of paint I don't
have to pay to use the paintbrush too
quick example let's say you have a sweet
calloused treasured shader
put it on there but if you want to get a
few more out of your vault or something
once you've acquired it then it might
cost you a few more so the mass deletion
of shaders might be a good thing so you
dump that currency into whatever you've
got and then if you need to go pull like
six or seven out just go pull them out
so this is a step in the right direction
for shaders which needed it in time
maybe that bad shada system so such like
it still shouldn't be a consumable in my
book but at least this is a way to step
words that maybe it's kind of the inter
woven system they can't break yeah cuz
it's been in a cold behind the scenes
that tie certain ones to glimmer and
like I remember a fellow who was on
somebody's show yeah DCPI bit broke it
down I think that's caught a problem so
it's just one of those like everybody
has to be a certain number and like to
use this you have to deduct one from its
there's to be something to actually use
I mean this day as you said it's
something in the code but this is at
least sounding like it's gonna be a lot
more manageable when we want whoa
when reacquiring gear from elections
what power level of a collections will
come out close to your current power
level but will require infusion to be
ready for in-game activities this is
basically a delicate balance of making
sure collections don't create a leveling
exploit but still provide that right so
I mean it makes sense they don't want
them because people find a way to
exploit this game you know people go to
jail well so if it's just below your
level you know it's not if it's five
below or something that's like you could
probably still jump into an activity if
you miss it for some reason or just know
like you know if you need to infuse
something go find that one thing and
then you're gonna go so I'm okay with
that that's most of what we've got for
the week so let me scroll back up to the
collections and but what are your
thoughts on the collections I know it
covered the gist of it but um you know
III just hit all I can hear right now is
definitely Gary still horn bling but um
yeah I mean listen is it a perfect
solution no but at the same time I think
is I think they've done a lot I think
that you know listen every that means
right now in theory again depending on
how much you trust Bungie in their
database right we could delete actually
all the unnecessary legendaries in my
fault right now right cuz in theory all
that stuff come for they can will be in
provided it's not a consumable will be
part of this collections thing for a
forsaken so I'm cool with that you know
you know flip a ton of space you know
they couldn't the base they were
transparent they couldn't figure out a
way to do the same process for the year
two weapons that have the roles like the
random roles so those ones you gotta
hold onto you know no I saw it that's it
again pretty tweet out you know
basically saying he's very concerned
we're gonna be back in the same
situation all over again you know I'm
saying once we get a ton of these random
rolls and to the extent he has a point
because he'd get guns with you know
different roles you want to try them out
and then I mean I was notoriously bad
for that indeed one I was horrible to
like not having you know three or four
you know what else I unis yeah
I saloon is like I had a bunch of those
that you want to play and you want to
get a feel of you know that kind of
thing is I get that I'm kind of a random
role hoarder in essence so I understand
that but um look I mean I still think
this is a good alternative you know I'm
saying for right now
you know maybe they come up with
something you know right now short-term
I feel it's good long-term yes I can see
them maybe you know something that's
kind of coming up along the way but um
I'm fine wait for the most part they're
like hopefully they can come up with a
even long-term solution for year two
stuff yeah I mean for I think it's a
balance it allows you to us to have all
the stuff we had in d1 if there's
something you're like hey I want to go
pull it out not really get it back it's
probably not too bad a little bit of
infusion that you're kind of good to go
to rock some old gun so that's actually
kind of cool it's a way to slightly
balance out because I mean I'm looking
through my inventory right now I've got
some like Praveena D hand cannon or just
all these old hand get bad news that
like all that crap I don't use right now
even if I dumped it I'm probably okay
losing it but it should be there if I
want it so some of that stuff just a
clear up space will be really nice
Armour as well I mean most of that's
just armor so that's not going to matter
so you don't need to keep any options so
most of that I'm thinking is honestly a
really good thing the shader as you said
it's not perfect but they're doing what
they can with the systems they have in
place and that's the best we can ask of
them and I think the way it sounds is
you may pick up 20 of something if you
like it keep them because you may want
to throw it on a new set of armor later
if there's rules and stuff but if you
don't really care about it and you've
like made a big collection you'll be
able to mass delete and then by the time
you're done you're kind
thank God for mass delete uh I'm out
brutal yeah what do I have the most of
blue geometry
Avalon's heal and Atlantis wash I have
what are you like 60 you know I gotta
get right 201 Atlantis wash o 69 Avalon
teal and blue geometry Jesus they don't
break down in too much so unfortunately
there's not a lot of benefit in doing
that so delete all please yeah so I mean
that should I like if I go through but
yeah so I'll probably end up deleting
most and honestly I'll delete most
because if I get bright dust from any of
them I'll hold on to that and then if I
really want it later fine but shaders
aren't the end of the world to me mm-hmm
but yeah we do have one more thing you
want to touch on so when it comes to
catalysts there's some of you guys
haven't seen yet and basically there's
going to be a way I don't know win if
it's summer solstice if this is forsaken
if this is not even real but there's
some exotic catalysts we just don't have
an option for yet and we're like where
the hell do we get these things so
dependently coming with the solstice of
Heroes is something called arms week
finally getting Banshee into it he looks
has been declawed and I hope they bring
something back with his random rolls and
his levels and stuff like that was
always a fun thing to do it's just
another if they wanted a hobby they got
enough to do so so apparently there's
gonna be an arm's week strike playlist
potentially as what the data farmers
have found requiring a specific weapon
loadout I guess it sounds almost maybe
similar to the way they're doing the
raids but not quite as elite of an
activity ooh
arms weak crucible playlist is on the
way also locked again pre described load
ass now that I actually think it was
really cool yeah there was a crucible
loadout where like everybody's using
auto rifles everybody's used as a bun
and everybody's swords then when heavy
pops it like it changes the game a
little bit so low
that I really dig and this is where I
wish they'd come in two more options in
crucible like let me give you ask you a
question not to cut you you know is this
arm we I don't do yet we have a
development map what is this arms week
of its supposed to happen
do we have a time frame uh I mean they
said testing to is getting it like up at
the top it's destined to getting smaller
but signaling data in July called the
solstice heroes among other things we
already know this but they think players
reckon they've worked out another part
of the update so it's not first sure
mm-hmm
but they think it's also severe Oh such
life I got first ish maybe when do we
because the reason I'm asking this is
when do we get bounties uh I'm looking
at the map bounties 1.2.3 so that's
actually the seventeenth so okay we're
close when I miss from d1 right and this
is what got me better in the crucible
massage true meaning the war and all
that they're training weapons yeah well
not the training weapons I'm actually
talking about remember when you used to
go in the tower and d1 shacks would be
on the right side right and then you had
his little robot helper friend on the
left at left hand side Wow
yes I know you're talking they would be
like get all these kills with autos
fusions pulses hand cannons and they
would rotate right hmm and it would be a
substantial experience thing right
you're deep one I don't miss that
because part of me like hey start be
level up and then part of part of it
help me get skilled at the weapon yes
that's how I used to touch any of the
archetypes I used to be in my bubble so
I kind of like this kind of thing where
arms weak is doing and I can see them
maybe possibly let's see how what they
do with bounties and if they're gonna
call and try to coincide some of this
stuff I'm very curious about Barney's
I'm dying to see what they do with that
man like this is exciting me i it's that
little extra minigame it makes you know
banshee useful i loved what i used to do
arms weak you did the test weapons
once in a while you got things
straightened out you know I'm cool with
this stuff man more stuff to do yeah
so I mean I did to him and that's one of
those and it was uh trying to think when
I really got an infusion rifles for me
was the thorn bounty honestly hmm as you
have because for me it was like I had to
go void I didn't have a great void power
like heavy weapon so I think I ended up
using fusions just to try and get more
kills and for me it kind of worked so
that was one of those times I wasn't
even forced but it was a way for me to
use something specific and that's kind
of what you're going for
give me a reason to use something
different little outside of my comfort
zone and train up with it but I'm gonna
get something from doing it all we're
asking for so this is nothing but good
stuff so my fingers that this stuff's
all real completely like delayed to
forsaken we don't know but hopefully the
reason I think partially it's coming
because what's coming next so arms weak
hmm there's some weapons right now that
you cannot hear anything about how do we
get a catalyst for it correct this is
where they're probably gonna come from
we're like Rat King Saros prospector
fighting lion that's most of them so we
know a curiously Pirtle esto those are
all gonna be on the raid so this is
enough they've already found and then
confirmed now so I think this is leading
to more accuracy so you've got one two
three four five so hardlight improves
weapons stability that's pretty much all
that gun needs yeah so it says founded
an arm's week activity possibly unique
nightfall strike so if there's a unique
strike loadout and that's like whatever
it is for the week then maybe you go run
that one with the arms Loic modifiers
get a chance at your heart light so Rat
King
creased aim-assist reduce recoil and
regenerates health wind vermin invisible
edge triggers effects a lot of stuff
arms week possibly nightfall in each one
I've seen this in a couple different
places because I think we talked about
this a couple times before so the ones
that you seem to be missing are probably
be going to come from this so if they
could do bounties if they can do
crucible or I'm so weak if they can add
this much more in here these are all the
pillars we've been talking about yes
that no forsaken yes so if you guys want
to see what I've been looking at this so
whoo you've got any PvE kill borealis
which will get that with forsaken
crimson Darcy tractor cannon world line
zero your basic PvE kills heroic strikes
nightfalls these the ones that I was
talking about some people need like 500
kills just to get one of the catalysts a
drop must let's do the rest of it
those are I mean maybe 500 I don't know
for what but I mean the dude said he was
like he did a pretty heated so many
strikes like 140 strikes didn't get any
started to impress teach nightfalls
finally saw him dropping so he stuck
with the prestige and was at least
actually starting to see him drop ever
like even every hundred nightfalls is
just insane that's ridiculous
huckleberry heroic and adventures I mean
that's just what other six of those to
do you had pretty much crucible any of
these I got colony colony I mean I'll
deal with the catalyst you know I don't
have I don't have them yet but these
these are out in the wild it just winds
right hasn't it always just in cool
kills victories yeah cannon kills
competitive is for meta multi-tools that
one's definitely harder to go grind but
I think I forget who died in coach or
somebody did a review on it recently and
it's like MIT is still outclassed other
stuff and reload speed don't really feel
that different so yeah but Colin
increased ammo serves 10 plus magazine
weapons each size so in fact I got a
shout out oh I gotta shut up this is the
asta cross gaming he's got yeah yeah
he's got a hilarious matomoto to
catalyst review it is because isn't it
the part was the part isn't it like me
knows we love speed
he is so funny he's like this is what we
want ejects we
all the way for this like he's so
disgusted especially in the current
matter with graviton and vigilance out
scouting any Scout you know yeah like
Jules rifles are basically put all
Scouts to shame because there's a medium
to long range and most of the time you
don't have like weld you don't it's
those two though I mean yeah it's those
two because the regular posters I'm a
scout can somewhat compete I mean Cruz's
base is the biggest one is graviton is a
better scout rifle than most because
it's so good on range this the two quick
like yeah graviton is putting Scouts the
shame vigilance is still that I think at
farthest range you should still be able
to outshoot a vigilance but if you get
into like medium long at all vigilance
is can start like right there in the mix
but I think at the farthest range but
that's where Scouts should be in that
crew that graviton is making them look
terrible yeah so I mean these are all in
there and then you got raids and you got
faction areas graviton all this stuff
Polaris Lance so this is from the quest
getting all five and here's what we're
talking about so this what everybody
thinks
alarms weak activities and it's gonna be
from found by engaging in activities
during the celebration of deadly
craftsmanship that worried that verbage
is too exact to be made up yeah that
that's that's that's what is its weak
yeah but yeah I got fighting lion after
this weapon fires equipped kinetic and
power weapons regain and gained a brief
period of increased handling precision
damaged because you fire it you switch
so I kind of cool and reload speed on it
desperately needed lard lights cool
prospector bigger blast radius
it's just weapon size that's got to be
something else you'll be really funny
goodies I want PvP big head but just for
fun
some really kills like that Rat King
does all stuff and cirrhosis this is the
one that might even be the coolest
increases chance for kills to regen
health I've met
where those literally on every single
Hill at now becomes a competition to
crimson you know almost like you know
it's gonna feel have it's gonna bring
back red death feels to you know say
like that every kill you know that might
be crazy that's a big deal and you only
got the bottom half of the magazine
doing extra damage that source will be
beast with that you know and then to
equip it you'll have your kills or
whatever it is but it's also like
complete the pyramidion when it's in
that week so you got two pieces one how
do you acquire these things is it gonna
be random or doing that stuff and then
to actually finish the catalyst you've
actually got to go do the right
nightfall alright week so if you miss it
on a week it's like man if I'm out of
town though I'm gonna miss it again some
of that stuff's like ah so but this is
just kind of a cool thing another thing
to do another thing to add more of the
Hobby type stuff I'm kind of I'm glad to
see this is coming back because Banshee
right now is just taking my glimmer for
nothing dumped but I have nothing but
spin it on some literally just live a
little
that's all I do again it's like I'm just
tired of the mods being the only thing I
spend it on there's not much else nice
but yeah I think that pretty much wraps
everything I had up for us this week a
lot of stuff going on in the world of
destiny mana I'm excited I like I like
what's going on you know I like mostly
for the most part some of the crucible
changes we still got to work on colore
fellas gotta get glory together yeah but
um you know for the most part I do like
what's going on on this catalyst stuff
that you bringing it towards the end
it's really cool you know I'm definitely
excited about that and prestige man the
400 stone you know that's cool um yeah
you know wit let's see let's see how
this thing all plays out I'm very height
for summer solstice I'm very height for
arms week that was a favorite of mine in
d1 you know I think I gotta get him
credit he I know as much as we complain
with certain things as much as they're
still not giving us all the information
behind the scenes or certain things now
I have to give them credit in this
regard generally in the lifespan of
Destiny the
some of mosul always slow the summer
yeah Taylor it tend to be and I like
that it feels like every every last
couple of jobs it's feeling like you
know every couple of every two weeks you
know weakens our two weeks we got some
activity to do you know right now it's
the cattle it's faxing really perfect
he'll know there's still things to fix
yes it but we actually play it right
we're actually trying to get these
things you know I'm saying you know I
think they're learning their own game
again and why we love it right so they
slowly you know peeling a layer of them
the casualization and the foolishness of
d2 david peel it away and get into that
core gameplay mechanic why we fell in
love with this game ah they love doing
this stuff okay tweaked a little bit
things here tweaked a little bit of
things they're you know keep engaging
with the feedback and like you said
building blocks to get in to that great
game that we all love and I'm who woulda
thought man like I know we still not out
the woods yet you know what we first
started doing flashpoints man like yeah
it was like people like what are we even
doing so are we doing right and we it
was just being you had this glimmer of
hope there just only been even the
hardcore I'm calling people and I'm
gonna have my name but even the most
hardcore destiny guys content creators
we're not covering it mm-hmm and we
stood by this game and we said okay if
they just do this and they just do that
and brick by brick please we almost
power should enough yes they almost did
hopefully hopefully this could be a
tremendous turnaround so I'm excited
destiny my friends are playing I'm happy
to see that you know I'm playing you
know it's getting there we're not
perfect we still got things we annoyed
with but it's getting there that's how I
feel I mean you kind of took all the
words right out of my mouth but yeah I'm
with you it's like there's a game we
still enjoy like when you when you're
literally just running around and
shooting stuff it still feels amazing
I mean it just all feels right now do
the guns hit hard enough do you feel
like a god all the time is that stuff
proper perfect no but as these pieces
get closer as these pillars get added to
the structure as they start building the
foundation for forsaken with a campaign
where we're gonna lose one of our van't
like big stuff happening random roles
come in late it was a misstep year one
they missed stepped in a lot of
different ways 4v4 no random roles like
the disconnection of the story and the
raid layers and not everybody loved and
all that stuff like but they're trying
different things I mean if you just made
sp1 all over again people would probably
crap all over them just for doing it all
over again
absolutely so it's they got to get up
there learned experiment and it's like
it's a moving target because you have
stuff like Division two you have anthem
have their own pieces as well
so funny you said those games comparison
of course I know you know it's great
comparison oh it's fine you said you're
gonna lead into uh when we get into get
into what we got play it for I okay but
yeah so it's like I mean those two I
played Division I enjoyed it up to the
point PvP got to a point of being really
annoying because I mean if it's just the
dark zone and that needed some help
that's coming back so we'll see but
leveling up to there like one to thirty
was cool but once he got to the endgame
honestly those things sucked and like
the raids have been amazing so I mean
Destiny's got that you don't have PDP
and anthem
straight up doesn't exist so that may
come later on but that's not literally
what you're playing in to do there's not
like neck warrior PvP or I mean it's
just it's gonna be all so I mean how
long can that sustain like the balance
of your seeming both has a lot to offer
and I and there are honestly some things
I like better in this like catalyst link
that is a great way for an exotic to
feel like you've got a billion how to
use it for also like that's one of those
things like if they didn't have the
misstep they would never have learned
and that a stroke I agree I agree and
then
even remember they're saying they're
gonna double down on that because I
remember watching a villa for forsaken
and they're doing stuff when I guess the
legendary took my other stuff like level
and those are level and nose and making
those your own so there's some other
mechanic with weapon investment that we
have yet to be revealed yet so it's like
you said you made a perfect point like
if they didn't slip and fall and just
kept the exact same formula we may not
even get masterworks we may not even get
all these things that you're talking
about that's a great point so I mean
that's kind of for me it's like it's
gonna moving-target some people have
moved away and hated it it's like we've
still play probably more than we should
I mean it's been nice to actually have
sorry random noise there yeah
just random website came up yeah but I
mean I've had a chance to step away and
play Detroit I've had a chance to play
God of War and those games give you nice
perspective on other stuff but as we
work through everything we've been
through it still has a lot to offer so
many people complain like I mean some
people do the dollar per hour that you
get out of a game destiny blows the
doors off of that if you want to try it
all even if you're gonna grind through
get up there and some of its repetitive
and I understand like not everything's
always unique start to finish but if
this is your type of game still got a
lot it's got a whole bunch more coming
yeah
I completely agree I completely agree
man we got the same point the rap
distinct yeah I'm just seeing like some
people who do count by the way the
artists out there in the world you guys
are amazing
yes work for Bungie whether you're doing
it on your own whether you're freelance
I'm looking at a picture to pop and
throw on Twitter of a forsaken ghost
that looks like a score and goes it
looks amazing
and I wish I was a creative art isn't
all you guys awesome stuff but I think
that's probably a good place to wrap it
good hour and a half long point for you
guys okay two hours you know but we got
some stuff to look forward to and
hopefully get a little more and
September's still looking good
September's gonna be hella busy with
games but I think this will be a good
thing to bounce back and forth between
even while if it's not all the time
so you good I think we'll have enough to
do to give you your in between play and
other stuff absolutely at a minimum so
at least that will kind of be back in
the hobby form but yeah you guys for me
it's Eve on ttis you can find me on
twitter combi montes for i'm not quite
as clever as some out there but you can
keep up with all I'm doing twitch.tv
slash Eve on ttis catch these live say
hey what's up I haven't been on there as
much lately but I still try and do it
when I can and then YouTube's the big
ones just for videos comments share like
all that stuff you guys follow me there
and hit that alert bell for both of us
post the video up YouTube's algorithms
are goofy enough at least that'll need
notification yang yep that's all I got
for you guys what about you yeah at
Lourdes kognito here on Twitter
obviously an incognito on Xbox company W
61 PlayStation switch we're not doing
friend codes right now but yeah man oh
we got this sunday will be the lord's
day on p.m. eastern standard and fingers
crossed should be a big one for us at
least um Eric's gaming trying to narrow
down a schedule and hopefully you can
still make it but so far systems are go
and um yeah man you know we gonna talk
about really good dude yeah he's he's
tremendous man I've been a huge fan of
Eric for a long time he's actually one
of the first content creators I actually
started watching destiny through VG 24/7
yeah calm site I used to go to a lot so
yeah I'm gonna you know we're gonna
break things down with him will and you
need UI you like my brother from another
mother because when you were talking
about anthem destiny Division 2 right
literally that's one of my talking
points as a question for him because
obviously we know he covers all those
games a monster hunter and hey so you
know I was dads I'll give you a sneak
peak one of the questions I'm gonna have
for him and one of our points is gonna
be you know the upcoming battle you know
it come February or whatever I mean
whenever these games launch you know um
both division two and which code entered
the fray
you know what's the strengths and
weaknesses are they gonna compete and
you actually go at it deserve up wait
like your like your TV you know this one
you know it's it's gonna be an
interesting matchup you know we'll
division will that's the improve all the
way in time she's a lot of goodwill
right now you know so it's gonna be
interesting things I want to pick his
brain
so again Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time knock on wood he's able to
still make the commitment I just got to
follow backup make sure I'm still good
and yeah man like I said and then
obviously you know here on their
personal isle of podcast channel we do
tons we're trying to do a little bit
more streaming a little bit um more
reviews Kings gonna be coming with a
combat talk and of course all convention
stuff you have up on the channel eat
three packs
you know when the Lords do hit those
events we try to give you guys behind
the scenes you know a little personal
from a fans fans perspective you know
how things are and of course the
incredible flashpoint would eat boxes
sane is always here we try to try to
keep it consistent Friday mornings you
know scheduled allow that will change
but thank you for rocking with us please
subscribe leave on to see boxes gotta
start hitting Twitter more so we can
promote a more go change so kind of been
just kind of low-key trying to get all
that done so I can finally get that
thing to pop out and fight me up that
way spoil it he's got some real cool
promotion of things he's gonna be ready
to show once they're ready I'm excited
get a little logo and brand done and
finally got a really good artist to help
me with that so it's what I'm looking
for yeah it's like I'm digging it and
then just working on the after-effects
to get a few animations in there so
video intros and stuff like that'll be
coming together so absolutely making
things look a little bit better
thanks for y'all for rockin with us this
morning man I definitely seen the
improvement and you guys sticking with
us man during the Dark Ages destiny all
the way to now and just standing chat
the engagement I saw a couple names in
there today Fonzarelli Chris Cole but
always one of our day ones yeah yeah
he's always here now really appreciate
you man it feels good to not talk to the
air leaders could talk all day that's
how about engaging
talking destiny and I have fun so we
gonna keep doing this thing for you
that's right yes
well more of you guys are at around the
world you never know good afternoon good
morning good evening whatever time
as for me have yourselves a good one
guys and thanks again no doubt please